hey guys Peter Brown here with a
gamespot news update following this
morning's news of a Microsoft layoff
spree turns out they're shutting down
their entertainment studios division the
department is responsible for original
Xbox programming and is tied into the
previously announced 18,000 employees
will be laid off from Microsoft over the
coming year in a statement issued a
gamespot Microsoft outlined its plan to
streamline a handful of portfolio and
engineering development efforts across
Xbox xes president nancy tellem an
executive vp jordan 11 will stay on and
remain committed to original programming
already in production so we'll still get
signal to noise the documentary series
that will cover among other subjects the
atari ET dig as well as halo nightfall
and Steven Spielberg's halo TV series
the halo projects will both continuous
plan to 343 industries entertainment
apps and the ability to watch TV through
the xbox one will not be impacted by
this move so how do you feel about these
layoffs so you're going to miss out on
Microsoft's TV programming or do you
think this is better for the Xbox
division at large let us know in the
comments below